hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast accelerating bio
production using XP chose stable
production medium presented by shreya
Lowe master scientist - in cell biology
at Thermo Fisher Scientific I'm Suzy
Valdez of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab routes and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information about our sponsor
visit WWF Fisher calm before we begin
I'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen types of
questions into the drop-down box that
appear on the screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on that ask a question box and let
us know you're having a problem please
join me now in welcoming our presenter
shreya aloe Master I will now turn the
presentation over to her
welcome shreya
I thank you for that presentation and
introduction so again my name is shreya
Lowe master today I will be speaking
about our newest product back we chose
stable production medium
so here's the overall agenda today I'll
be focusing on the transient to stable
solutions for cho cells and focusing and
highlighting on one main pain point
how can you seamlessly transition from a
research skill into a commercial scale
process followed by a highlight on the
transient expression versus a stable
production workflow and then a case
study that we performed of how we
created a high producing X Beach OS
stable clone and concluded with a
summary
so this is the transient to stable
solution so credibly researchers are
demanding higher titers and transient
systems the transient tro systems are an
emergence emerging alternative over HEC
two nine three systems currently on the
market there is XP Chow expression
system kit this is a kit that will
enable you to have transient expression
pool used in the research skill only
once you go through your stable clone
development process and into your
production phase that is when you can
transition into the XP chose stable
production medium again for commercial
scale production these two products are
completely integrated into one system
creating a one solution for you
so this is highlighting again the xb2
expression system kit that is out on the
market as well this kit again is for
enabling transient expression and
producing high titers but the most
important part is it uses the high
density xvlx host cell line within the
expression system kit depending on the
protocol you choose to use there are
three protocols with standard high titer
and Max titer protocol the standard is a
more simplistic and faster high titer is
in between and then the max titer is the
longest and requires the most complexity
this depends on different temperature
shifts applied and necessary for your
protein of choice but irregardless of
which protocol you choose you can see
that these high density xp show us host
cell lines are higher in tighter
production in the transient system in
comparison to our competitors as well as
their xB 293 and this week would be the
same exact cells used for your stable
clone development needs
this is a complete Cho transient
expression system that exists again on
the market today the exit OS sells that
I just mentioned are a higher producer
and select for higher transduction
efficiency paired with that is the SP
Festa mean Cho transfection tip this is
a higher efficiency lipid-based
transfection kit and again paired with
this is the XP Cho expressions medium
this is the transaction medium that is
optimized for your XP Cho s cells as
well as optimized to work with the X
defect amine kit to give you excellent
transfection efficiency and higher
titers and these are all three available
within the SP Cho expression system kit
and they're currently on the market for
transient expression
so these first three components are also
used for your stable clone development
you can transition into our recently
launched commercial scale up medium at
any point post transaction which is a
stable production medium again this is
integrated into the XP Cho family of
products the XP chose stable production
medium is available in liquid as well as
a GT a GT is our advanced granulation
technology powder which is a dry
granulated material that I will speak
about shortly and it is great for
shipping and storage needs and from this
point forward I will be referring to XP
Cho expression medium as expression
medium an XP chose stable production
medium as stable production medium
so again I just mentioned that AGT the
dry format gives you simplicity to help
your streamline scale up the key
benefits of this are that it is auto pH
you simply add water and it will get you
to the correct Auto pH and Auto Osmo
settings it has a FAQ fast solubility
and mixed time it also has a dust free
addition to your tank the granulation
allows this and there's minimal
filtration pressure build-up and again
you don't have to have too much space to
store this this will still go into your
2 to 8 degree refrigerator but the
powder will take up much less room than
liquid work and again XP chose stable
production medium is available in a GT
and gives you these time-saving benefits
now how you have an idea of the
integrated xp show family of products I
would like to focus on a pain point and
a typical workflow for stable home
developments
so this is a stable clone development
and it's a cone process to scale up into
your larger buyer production processes
first you begin with your target
selection with your pool followed by
your stable clone development after
stable clone development you would
normally go into a medium screening and
optimization phase
generally speaking you would use a
medium that is optimized for your
cloning process and once you've cloned
you would transition into a production
medium in your manufacturing process
most of the time these two products are
not integrated with each other for this
reason it will take much longer to adapt
yourself and can take up to an average
of six months in order to adapt yourself
and that's the point that you can go
into scaling up into your larger bio
production needs
with sex we chose stable production
medium scientists can completely bypass
this mediums screening and optimization
stuff again the reason for this is you
eliminate it because it is an integrated
XP Cho
system these are a family of products
that are designed to work together that
eliminates the step of needing to adapt
yourself you can simply go straight into
your scale-up needs in our larger
bioreactor
these are comparing the two workflows so
the transition into the XP Cho stable
production medium will be highlighted
first the expression system kit is used
for the transient workflow so you can
see that the expression medium is used
through the entirety of the transient
workflow you begin with the transmission
phase with your vector choice and the
transfection reagent and depending on
the protocol you choose to use you add
an enhancer and feed or apply a
temperature shift and then on day 14 you
would harvest your titer on day 14 once
you harvest your titer your cells are
not at their peak viable cell density or
viability nor are they at their peak
protein production and for this reason
it's important to highlight that it's
one transfection
per transient production if you would
like more harvest you would have to
completely reapeat this entire 14-day
process whereas in a stable workflow
again you use the XP Chow expression
system kit for your transaction and for
transfection you use the expression
medium again with your vector choice and
your transfection reagent but upon
transduction and right after you can use
XP chose stable production medium it's
important to note that stable production
medium is not optimized for high
transaction efficiency so it is
recommended to use at any point post
transaction and then once you go through
that you go into your selection phases
and then you go on to clone selection
once you select your clone you can put
down a master cell bank for multiple
productions this master cell bank is
very very beneficial and the reason for
this is once you go through this process
while it is longer upfront you have a
master cell Bank of your high producing
stable clock and you can go into your
scale-up needs multiple times for
repeatedly without having to repeat this
workflow so it saves time in the long
run
is comparing the transient and stable
production with the products so
transient expression uses the ex beach
OS cells as well as the xB 2 expression
medium which is a transaction medium and
then the xB fected mean show
transfection kit it's important to
highlight that the stable production
uses the xB Cho s high-density cells
that have a high transaction efficiency
and currently they are available as non
P GMP cells however you can license them
for your commercial needs by contacting
out licensing at thermo Fisher comm or
you can decide to wait until they launch
later this year and again the a speech
or expression medium is used for
transmission along with the SPF ectomy
and cho transfection kit and at this
point this is when we introduce the XP
Cho stable production medium again once
you have your stable clone and you
perform the transmission it will support
your stable and scale-up needs so now
that I've introduced you to our
integrated XP show family of products
I would like you'd like to walk you
through a case study of how we developed
a high producing stable pause so this is
our case study of a high producing XP
gos stable clone you start with thawing
and XP Cho less stable Bank and
performing stable transfection at that
point you would go through a selection
phase in our case we went through two
selection phases in order to select the
integrated clone expressing your gene of
interest we followed this by using
limited dilution cloning this is what we
used we also know there are other
systems available on the market there
are also viable options but this is our
proof of concept and this is what we
decided to use and then we followed it
by clone screening in the primary
secondary and tertiary in order to see
what sort of productivity assessment we
received and finally we followed this by
a stability assessment to check to see
if the stable clone is producing a
higher titer without losing expression
along the way
a stable corn selection before I get
into this I would like you to look at
the bottom right of the image for the
overall workflow overview and the part
that is grayed out is the part that I am
focusing on so it starts at the top left
of that small image and then goes to the
right back down and all the way back to
the left so there's any confusion it is
on the bottom right of the screen so
this is a selection process that will
help to get diverse tools to increase
your chances of a high producing stable
clone selection one was a low antibiotic
pressure and once we received higher
than or greater than 85% viability we
proceeded into selection to once they
recovered we went into selection - and
this is a higher antibiotic pressure and
once they are greater than 90 percent
viability we followed it by limited
dilution cloning
this is a closer look at our limited
dilution quoting this is our proof of
concept and feasibility studies which
resulted in a stable cross as you can
see we go through the ex vitro s pool
and then we played a half a sell for
well in 96 well plate and perform a
static incubation and then we expand it
respectively and then this five-day
assessment is six while shaking plates
is actually our primary screening for
the clone and then from that we select
clones to expand into 125 ml shape us
and we create a small working cell Bank
so I just mentioned that we went through
a primary screening as well as we
followed it with a secondary screening
the primary and secondary screening are
both a glucose only productivity
assessment and at that point we also
performed a stability assessment and
then followed by that we went into the
tertiary clone screening which is a Fed
batch process that we use efficient feed
C+ and from this we selected the stable
clone that is an XP show s clone that
produced greater than 3 grams per liter
of IgG titer from this clone we
performed multiple experiments to see
how they worked in our how it worked in
adaptation and how it would work into a
bioreactor so as you can see this is the
same stable XP chile's clones
it was passaged every 3 to 4 days and
then the cells receded at to e5 cells
per mil and shake pots so in red is the
XP Cho expression medium which is our
control and then XP Cho stable
production medium is shown in blue and
then to competitors and the XP Cho as
you can see the XP show stable
production medium shows that there was
no adaptation required and attained very
similar growth with the control again
the expression medium and in addition to
this the cell growth is much higher than
the competitor media
so at this point we went through the
adaptation and we proved out that there
really is no requirement for adaptation
if you're going for expression medium
into the stable production medium so we
went now into the amber 15 bioreactor as
you can see this is a stable the same
stable X peach OS clone in an amber 15
in a fed batch process again using the
efficient feed C plus at a 2 X
concentration and you can see that we
the competitor medium is also paired
with the competitor feed and it's
important to note that in blue which is
the AG T of X we show stable production
medium and in red the liquid version of
stable production medium there is no
variability between the two formats and
growth and that's in fun because
generally speaking you would develop
your product in our liquid and then
scale up into an A GT for your larger
manufacturing needs
so again the same impact
study and in this case we're looking at
what sort of IgG titer production did we
receive again between the two formats
and Vance granulation technology and the
liquid there is absolutely no
variability between the format's and
tighter as well as the growth and in
addition to this it also outperformed
competitor medium
so once we started and looked at the
adaptation results and then we followed
it by by looking at what kind of
productivity did we get in a small
bioreactor we wanted to translate this
into a larger bioreactor
so we use the 50 liter single use
bioreactor as shown on the left and this
is again the same stable ex-beatle s
clones and a fed batch process using the
XP show stable production medium a GT
format with the efficient feed C plus at
a 2 s concentration and the initial run
seems to translate well from a small
bioreactor without any process
optimization or feed optimization as you
can see on the first graph the viable
cell density has a nice high peak
density and it holds on and in the right
graph you can see that the IgG titer
hits nearly 3 grams per liter of protein
tighter on day 14 showing that it is a
scalable process and the medium also is
scalable
so in summary XP show stable production
medium is a scalable solution for stable
protein production it's a new medium
that was introduced that facilitates the
seamless transition from your transient
knees into your stable protein
expression intro so and again it's
important to reiterate that there is no
adaptation required when going from
transient expression in an XP Cho
expression medium to the XP show stable
production medium the medium also
supports large-scale by our production
runs using the license high density xB
gos cells and again it's available in a
liquid and advanced granulation
Technology format if you would like to
have a free 1 liter sample of the xB
show stable production medium please
contact your thermo Fisher Scientific
sales reps
and I would like to thank the Rd support
team as well as our business support
team thank you
Thank You shreya for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question drop box located on the far
left of your presentation window type
your questions into that box that appear
on the screen and click the send button
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for so let's take a look at
our incoming questions from our audience
members and welcome audience
that the first question coming in is
what is the difference between ex vicho
stable production medium and the
existing kit
so the existing kit that has this XP Cho
expression medium is a transmission
medium and again once you go through
your transaction at that point any point
post transaction is one you can transfer
into or transition into using the stable
production medium the reason for this is
you can scale it up into a large
bioreactor
thank you and when do you use XP Cho
stable production medium so again you
would use this at any point post
transaction and thank you and what
vector do you recommend
right now the vector we are recommending
is the PC DNA 3.3 or the PC DNA 3.4
vector thank you for that and thank you
audience for your incoming questions our
next question from our audiences is this
kit suitable for commercial on
recombinant therapeutic protein
production like freedom Chow s kit and
here's a second part of that also is it
ok for GMP regulations and last part of
that is in addition I wonder the plasmid
used in this kit does include dhfr
system for gene application Oh
amplification part of me so I the mister
cannot be spoken about it is proprietary
however it is okay for cGMP regulations
as far as I don't know if that's a
reference to the actual cells being used
I don't know if that's what is being
asked about
do you want to repeat part of that I can
see the question on
I think it's if it's according to the
cell lines of X beach OS host cell line
yes they are ok for cGMP regulation
thank you our next question is what
selection system is being used to select
the stable clones again the vector is a
proprietary vector that I cannot reveal
that unfortunately
thank you our next question is it more
productive than freedom chow s kit and
which one would you suggest for
commercial ma B production
that's a very good question so the
freedom show us tit is a great kit
however the most important factor about
this XP show family is if you're already
using the XP show expression system kit
and you've already gone through
transient expression with that that's
when you can transition into your stable
clone development needs
so it's integrated so you eliminate that
step of having to switch your
transfection medium and then production
media and it's already a you it's a
time-saving
factor for what sort of monoclonal
antibody production which is better and
more productive it depends on your
vector of choice as well as your gene of
interest
thank you and again I want to thank our
audience members for their participation
and any questions not answer today feel
free to write them in and they will be
answered via email by the presenter we
have one more question coming in is the
high expression of antibiotic resistant
genes a problem with regulatory
authorities
ah
[Music]
you
I do not think that that should be a
problem
hey to my knowledge there should not be
a problem okay thank you very much
and shred do you have any closing
remarks for our audience members before
we close today
if anyone again would like a free 1
liter sample of our liquid éxito stable
production medium we are more than happy
to supply that and if there's more
questions feel free to contact myself
thank you very much for your
presentation today and your important
research I'd also like to thank Thermo
Fisher Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2019
please share with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event also
stay tuned for our next presentation
strategies for high titer protein
expression using the X P Cho and xB to
9-3 transient expression systems
presented by dr. John the Muto the
director of cell biology life sciences
solution group at Thermo Fisher
Scientific you don't want to miss out
that's all for now and thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye bye and have a great day